there was a curious development during
the shutdown one I know that some of you
saw because you tweeted me about it
MSNBC and Chuck Schumer on different
occasions going after yours truly for
holding the line as I have for many many
years on illegal immigration the
Republicans in the House have been and
it depends on where you sit some people
would say supported by others would say
terrorized by news outlets like
Breitbart like Gloria Grahame
terrorizing oh no tell me she's not
calling me out for terrorizing House
members I do say when was the last time
Casey hunt mentioned mentioned the
illegal immigrants who actually do
terrorize American citizens we're gonna
get to this and a few segments ms-13 and
what they're doing to areas right
outside of DC roving gangs of hardened
ruthless criminal criminals who are
terrorizing American citizens when
offenders with multiple deportations
stop reentering the country and
terrorizing our people that's when I'll
stop terrorizing congressmen about the
issue thank you very much and speaking
of terror Chuck Schumer actually
suggested that the president was about
to sign on to the Graham Durban daca
deal until big bad Laura showed up the
hard-right came after him
Breitbart calls him amnesty Trump Laura
Ingraham even insisted he be impeached
by the weekend
he had backed off not only has he been
embarrassed today with his political
ineptitude now Chuck Schumer is just
flat-out lying I never ever said that
the president should be impeached he
must be confusing me with I don't know
make a brazil ski or something I have no
idea but I said the president's base
would be watching the dacha deal very
closely and they wouldn't stand for
amnesty and you know what they obviously
won't and wouldn't I also said on this
show that the president's enemies want
him impeached I've said that from the
beginning so Chuck I suggest you get a
better strategy team
you get your facts straight don't put
words in my mouth unless you're willing
to come on the show we've invited you
and defend them